madame monsieur bonsoir 2h25 2h25 de
bonheur d'inquiétude d'émotion de
chaleur de sueur pour les deux joueurs
qui se sont affrontés
cet après midi en finale à roland garros
pour eux mais aussi pour tous ceux qui
les observaient les spectateurs
privilégiés du court central et les
millions de téléspectateurs rivés à leur
télévision
superbe combat entre yannick noah numéro
six du tennis mondial et mats wilander
numéro 5 et vainqueur l'année précédente
un superbe combat entre deux superbes
garçon dont on a pu admirer le jeu
parfaitement complémentaires et les
tempéraments parfaitement opposé deux
heures 25 minutes et une victoire en
trois manches pour yannick noah 6 2 7 5
et 7 6 au tie break
les grands moments de la rencontre
lionel chamoulaud et c'est marcel
bernard le dernier vainqueur français de
roland garros qui remet le trophée à
yannick noah depuis 1946 aucun français
n'avait été ce geste
une immense joie pour le clan noah
toutes les données de cette rencontre
était connue d'avancé
les deux hommes se connaissent par coeur
deux façons de jouer en dynamique à leur
restait à savoir qui allait imposer son
jeu
tournon à celle attaque et la volée
[Musique]
pour mats wilander le tenant du titre le
front de cours et les passing-shots est
très vite nous serons fixés yannick
impôts sa présence physique il est le
maître du court le suédois ne réussit
pas ses passings wilander subi la
rencontre et noah remporte la première
manche 6 2 en 38 minutes
[Applaudissements]
le conseil en début de deuxième set ne
lâche pas son adversaire
il prendra par deux fois le service du
suédois pour mener 3 à 2 et 1 5 jeux à 3
wilander n'est tout de même pas le
tenant du titre pour rien il ne veut pas
lâcher la partie
[Applaudissements]
patrice hagelauer et jean paul loth
relativement détendus pour l'instant
yannick est bien en jambes
d'ailleurs qu'il semble inaccessible
noah depuis le début pour moi personne
ne lui résiste
ghani a fait chavirer le central mais
wilander s'il ne réussit pas ses
passings tente des lobs liftés et
reviendra à 5 jeux partout
il faudra alors en eau a terriblement
volontaires pour gagner la deuxième
manche par 7 jeux à 5
noah tient roland garros à portée de
raquette
la troisième manche sera la plus
disputée noah accusent le coup
physiquement et le suédois rouen
confiance ses balles sont mieux ajuster
les deux hommes iront dans cette manche
jusqu'au tie break et je vous laisse
apprécier le plus beau point de la
rencontre
[Applaudissements]
noualhat veut tellement cette victoire
qui fait littéralement exploser vie en
vert avec son service
angoisse dans le clan noah deuxième
balle de match pour yannick c'est la
bonne 7 3 au tie break 6 2 7 5 7 6
yannick noah a réalisé mon rêve
[Applaudissements]
toujours envie de faire de partager
c'est pas tellement que je sois comme ça
mais je pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui le méritent avec moi les patrice et
là il ya jean paul également il ya toute
la fédération
tous ces gens qui ont travaillé avec moi
depuis très longtemps et je pense que
c'est un peu le fruit tout ce travail en
commun que cette victoire à roland
garros et j'espère que bon derrière ça
suivra que ça donnera de l'ambition à
d'autres jeunes parce que c'est pas
parce qu'on est français qu'on perd en
finale ou qu'on fait de bons résultats
de temps en temps on peut également de
gagner et je pense qu'on l'approuvé tous
ensemble aujourd'hui